ok
je crois qu'on ne devrait pas rester là
qu'est ce que tu fais là c'est en train
de vider mon ca tue et adam riess né le
10 février 2010 qu'on a la même
cicatrices tu as la montre de mon père
au produit je suis moi c'est top secret
mais oui ça pour l'annoncé par les
hommes de la terre tout ce que tu fais
en ce moment même dans le seul but de la
secourir ça va changer les futures dans
l'avenir est catastrophique non c'est
une blague c'est pas une blague s'il
allait bien si je comprends bien tu es
prêt à risquer ta jeune vie ça me désole
qu'on doive en arriver là
si on réussit pas on rentre pas
je te montre très cool j'étais sûr que
c'était un sabre laser
[Musique]
il est trop chaud ce gosse non non pas
envie de tenir sa tête sous l'eau
jusqu'à ce qu'elle ait plus aucune pub
tue et adam reed né le 10 février 2010
on a la même cicatrices
juste là et tu as la montre dans mon
père au poignet
je suis moi
non mais puise top secret mais oui
le voyage dans le temps existe
je vais pas intéressé au but c'était
2018 remonter le temps pour la sauver et
me parlent et je suis sûr que tu en
prends plein de règles retrouvez le
tu veux que je te montre un truc cool
j'arrive pas à quoi que tu sois là
comment c'était trop bien rangement
tu sais ce qu'ils te reste à faire
empêcher que le voyage dans le temps
sont à inventer accroche toi
le grand show
adam papa papa
on ne peut pas contrôler le voyage dans
le temps
mais jamais été inventé
si on réussit pas on rentre pas aucun de
nous deux gert inquiète
[Musique]
tu t'es déjà fait rita mes parents
meurent de deux ans avec un final at her
c'est l'heure de la famille nombreuse